und uns zugeschaltet ist dazu jetzt
siegfried russwurm der präsident des
bundesverbandes der deutschen industrie
schönen guten abend nach mich
gut um vergebung wir haben es gerade
gehört handel und handwerk warnen vor
einem bankrott welle weil unternehmen
die hohen energiepreise nicht mehr
bezahlen können wie sieht es denn bei
ihnen in der industrie aus fürchten sie
schon um arbeitsplätze
also die situation ist kritisch in allen
unternehmen plant ein land aus mir geht
es ähnlich wie in meinem kollegen
wollseifer gerade eben auch ich krieg
täglich neue katastrophenmeldungen und
es trifft unternehmen aller art große
wie kleine die möglichkeiten aus der
situation irgendwie herauszukommen die
mögen unterschiedlich sein aber es ist
wirklich allerhöchste not in der
deutschen wirtschaft wie soll denn jetzt
aus ihrer sicht die politik gegen diese
allerhöchste not vorging
nun ich glaube es ist sehr schnell klar
zu machen pflaster hinten werden nicht
helfen wir können mit allen
steuergeldern es nicht schaffen diese
kostenlawine hinten auszugleichen wenn
die kosten entstanden sind wir müssen
alles dafür tun dass energie wieder
billiger wird in deutschland das hilft
aber übrigens allen den privaten
kundinnen und kunden genauso wie den
wirtschaftlichen verbraucher also alles
tun was energie kostengünstig gemacht
dass jetzt aber leichter gesagt als
getan wie macht man den energiekosten
sich günstiger heißt das sie wollen
wieder pipelinegas aus russland
importieren
nein nein es gibt zwei große hebel die
wir haben das eine so banal es klingt
angebot und nachfrage bestimmen massiv
den preis heißt ja wir müssen alle
energie sparen aber gleichzeitig müssen
wir zum beispiel strom erzeugen mit
allem was geht dass das nicht erfreulich
ganz klar aber wir müssen das
stromangebot erhöhen alles das was da zu
helfen kann sollte dringend zugeschaltet
werden und der zweite hebel auch heute
noch sind energiepreise in deutschland
mit jeder menge steuern und abgaben
belegt auszeiten die grund energie
günstig war auch da muss der staat muss
die regierung noch mal hin fassen und
zur dinge wie den netzkosten von den
energiepreisen wegnehmen auch das hilft
den unternehmen das bringt uns nichts
zurück in die guten zeiten ganz billiger
energie aber es hilft zumindest den
faktor acht und zehn den wir heute mit
wettbewerbs ländern sehen doch ein
bisschen auszugleichen also rückkehr zur
kernenergie und zur kohleenergie und ein
extra entlastungspaket wie die
wirtschaft aber richtig ist ja auch dass
die unternehmen lange jahre von billigem
gas aus russland profitiert haben dazu
gab es reichlich corona hilfen und jetzt
stellt sich die industrien und fordert
wieder geld haben sie gar keine reserven
haben sie nicht vorgesorgt
und die unternehmen haben natürlich
reserven aber ich nehme jetzt bewusst
das beispiel eines da nicht
energieintensiven gefahr dass ein
maschinenbauer der hat vielleicht nur
zwei prozent energiekosten in alt bei
einer verzehnfachung der kosten heißt es
plötzlich er hat 20 prozent so viel
profit macht ja nicht so viel kann ja
nicht durchsetzen bei seinen kunden im
globalen wettbewerb und dann sind ihre
hafen ganz schnell aufgebraucht und
natürlich müssen unternehmer dann
überlegen welche alternativen haben wir
denn was mich am anfang überrascht hat
auch familienunternehmen die jetzt die
frage stellen sind wir eigentlich mit
unserer produktion in deutschland noch
richtig dabei oder müssen wir uns andere
standorte in der welt anschauen bevor
wir unser geschäft stilllegen sie haben
eine umfrage gemacht vom bdi und da da
hat jedes fünfte unternehmen gesagt es
denkt über eine verlagerung der
produktion ins ausland nach wenn das so
käme hätte dann nicht putin seinen
wirtschaftskrieg gegen deutschland
gewonnen indem er den industriestandort
deutschland erfolgreich schlecht
wir haben in der tat diese umfrage
gemacht um aus den elektronischen
geschichten rauszukommen eine echte
solide basis zu haben über 600
unternehmen befragt und das ergebnis war
wirklich grauenhaft umso mehr müssen wir
alles tun damit putin eben nicht gewinnt
müssen diesen unternehmen helfen aber
wie gesagt hinten nachzuhelfen durch
unterstützungsmaßnahmen des staates das
werden wir nicht schaffen dazu ist das
problem viel zu groß wie wollen sie
einem unternehmen helfen dass plötzlich
8 fach höhere energiekosten hat das
achtfache höherer kosten hat als sein
wettbewerber in usa und am weltmarkt
konkurrieren will deswegen wir müssen
vorne anfangen alles tun was uns hilft
energie
preiswerter zu machen und dazu muss in
der tat alles produzieren was irgendwie
geht
energiepreis weitermachen ich glaube das
ist eine forderung der kann sich im
moment jeder anschließend vielen dank
siegfried russwurm präsident des
bundesverbandes der deutschen industrie